And the answer, at least at the time of writing, is 16.
And if it's actually different from 16,
we'll have our grading script update accordingly.
Let me show you how I arrived to this answer.
All right. So here we are in Python I first import the libraries I need.
URL of two and Mini dom.
Okay and then I download the New York Times page.
I'm going to use URL lib to URL open and I'm pasting the URL.
I'm going to go ahead and call read on that to download the contents and
we're going to store that under a variable called contents.
We can take a peek at contents.
There we go.
A lot of stuff and looks like RSS.
We can see the closing RSS tag there.
Now we're going to parse this with Mini Dom.
Okay. That worked, got a variable d, it's got a document instance, and
I'm going to use get elements by tag name, item, to find all of those.
So let's give this a whirl.
Success.
And then we just run length on this.
Okay and the answer's 18 [LAUGH].
So grading this is actually going to be a little tricky for
us, all we wanted you to do is go through this process.
So hopefully, that worked out for you and you got a number.
And hopefully, we managed to grade that number.
That's how you parse some basic XML, I think you can see probably, the value
here and that many webpages have XML, interfaces them, or RSS interfaces them.
Where you can actually download their content, and
manipulate it, from a program.